two fraternities at one of the country's
most prestigious liberal arts colleges
voted to disband overnight over images
and video that appear to show former
members making racist remarks and joking
about rape Swarthmore College faced days
of protests after the leak of the
internal documents dozens of students
occupied the five fraternity building in
a statement last night members of that
fraternity said this we cannot in good
conscience be members of an organization
with such a painful history Meg Oliver's
on the Swarthmore is on the Swarthmore
campus that's outside of Philadelphia
with this very dramatic decision make
those images were very disturbing good
morning to you very disturbing indeed
good morning Gail the campuses only
other fraternity Delta Epsilon also
decided to shut down overnight
D you brother said in a statement that
it was quote in the best interest of the
Swarthmore community this comes after to
campus publications released what they
say are fraternity videos and photos
provided by an anonymous source last
month the material is dated between 2013
and 2016 and contains racist homophobic
and sexist comments allegedly from
brothers of by psy it also appears to
show men kissing groping and touching
women who may not have known they were
being recorded
there's even reference to Delta Epsilon
having a rape attic in its building once
worth more senior showed us what she
describes as a similar room at facade
she claims she was sexually assaulted in
their building her freshman year
Swarthmore officials wouldn't tell us
that they plan to ban Greek life moving
forward but in an email to students
president Valeri Smith said Swarthmore
is committed to fully investigating any
allegations of sexual misconduct or
violations of its student code
Margaret Meg Oliver disturbing but thank
you for that update